abis stands for advancement of blacks
and sports it's an organization that is
proudly one of the voices of racial
equity in sports and after all the work
they do year round it is time to
celebrate this memorial day weekend so
let's welcome ceo and founder of abis
gary charles to the show welcome hey how
are you doing i'm good good now we're on
the same page we're matching yeah i
didn't notice that okay so this is
that's a good thing that's a good thing
we're on the same page because we'll be
working together this weekend
but before we talk about champions and
legends weekend let's talk about abis
and just what your mission is
well we want to be um the voice for
racial equity in sports you know that's
when it comes down to that's that's what
it is i think too many people have been
hurt in the sports world as far as in
our community and we want to stop that
so we want to be that voice for it the
naacp of sports i like that i like that
and of course helping blacks and sports
but also celebrating them so let's get
to the weekend memorial day weekend
what's on the lineup explain what we're
celebrating well we're celebrating us i
felt that there's no reason for us to
have to wait for someone else to tell us
how we should celebrate and how we
should let people know the things that
we've done amen so this weekend is going
to be a culmination of people that
people need to recognize and understand
what they've done in our community
absolutely and one of the board members
for abis is nikki fargus of the aces
president of the aces why is vegas the
perfect place to bring this event you
know what i've been coming to vegas
since 1991
with my own basketball team new york if
you couldn't tell
i have no idea what you're talking about
but that's another story
but um so
been coming here this whole time
i felt that vegas was the exact spot to
go ahead and put something on like this
and one of our other members
on the board dave lato
the former coaching university of
virginia
and depaul university um he also thought
this was a the right spot to make this
happen and with nikki being here yeah
and being a board member oh he was just
spoiled aligning at the right time
absolutely the greatest arena on earth
is the perfect place for this event and
who are we honoring on saturday for the
gala the epic awards gala this is your
first annual and myself my tv neighbor
brian salmon will be emceeing the event
so what can we expect
there's a couple things that we're doing
one is that we are naming certain awards
after certain people and then people are
going to receive those particular awards
okay for example we had the jacket join
the courtesy excellence award awesome
and allison felix is going to be
receiving that one
we have the shaquille o'neal economic
and sustainability award okay and that's
going to go to albert king
we have the vivian stringer pioneer
award that's going to go to dawn staley
but also we also want to recognize
allies so we have the sunny vacal
champion of change award and that's
going to go to former miami coach brian
flores who's now with the steelers
because you know giving up your career
like that right that changes yeah okay
so he's he's going to earn that okay
he's earned that uh dr j
dr j
mentioned dr david you're going to be
receiving the lifetime achievement award
okay
then how about we have the william c
rhoden sports media award that's going
to go to jameel hill beautiful one of my
one of my someone that i look up to okay
we got a wrap now so how can people get
tickets because there's still tickets
available for friday's events saturday's
events and sunday's events it's an
entire weekend
please go to abis
champion legends dot eventbrite.com
all right all right please show up
support so we can stay here in vegas
all right stay here baby thank you so
much charles gary